[Musique]
une élection municipale partielle à
chevreuse le dimanche 9 mai les
habitants étaient appelés aux urnes pour
élire leur maire après l'annulation du
scrutin de 2020 c'est à néry le pallec
qu'il emporte avec près de 62% des voix
plus d'ateliers philosophiques en école
primaire nadia et à signer une
convention avec l'association sève la
ministre délégué en charge de la ville
étaient pour l'occasion aux déplacements
dans plusieurs établissements trappistes
à la réserve naturelle de saint quentin
en yvelines on observe les oiseaux et on
les protège depuis 35 ans près de 230
espèces ont été recensées le site s'est
agrandie pour devenir la réserve
naturelle des étangs et rigole d'yveline
elle en rêvait rêve de seniors et le zoo
de thoiry l'ont aidé à le rendre réel
marie 70 ans habitant du tremblay sur
mauldre a fait la connaissance de ye ba
a beau temps beau et brillant goût les
quatre gorille du parc les services de
réanimation des hôpitaux et cliniques
franciliens se sont vus dotés de 500
lits modulaire une enveloppe de 10
millions d'euros financés par la région
ile de france à partir de fonds
européens
plus que quelques jours à patienter
avant de rouvrir les commerces
restaurants et bars se préparent à la
reprise de leurs activités avec la mise
en place d'un protocole sanitaire
le centre commercial westfield vélizy 2
a notamment installé des capteurs de co2
[Musique]